foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
so
Andrew Tate
oh he's definitely gonna end up on the
bonehead list what do you think
he's definitely a contender for bonehead
of the week no question about it
what a cuck
oh my God you can't get any more beta
mail than Andrew Tate's video yesterday
after
Greta thundberg absolutely owns him on
Twitter
what the oh Jesus Christ I can't I can't
even believe that this is a thing in our
universe
that exists
um elon's Twitter's done this to us
Andrew Tate was banned
from Twitter
Elon gave him his account back
um we now can see
in plain sight why his account was taken
away from him
hell [ __ ]
Jesus
did you watch the um the response video
that he that he made for Greta
I mean we're gonna show it
of course of course I have to show this
because yesterday
um our great moderator MJ pointed out
that
Greta had responded to him with her
email
um
and the email was small dick energy at
get a life.com
um
he he really and we watched the video
yesterday where he thought the Matrix
was real or something I don't know what
the [ __ ] he's talking about to be quite
honest with you
about the Matrix in the movie does he
think the the movie The Matrix is real
life
is that what he thinks
I I mean I don't [ __ ] know
look I'm a little hungover
and this morning
um Gabe Sanchez is still feeling under
the weather so I don't know if we're
gonna have him today or not
hmm So today we're going to talk about
Republican frauds George Santos again
because there's a criminal investigation
being opened now I guess so there's news
and we're going to talk about
um small dick energy Andrew Tate
but the other thing I want to mention
which is very important is there is more
transcripts dropping today see
uh the reason why Donald Trump is
terrified of the January 6 select
committee is because of the drip drip
drip there's been one thing that the
January 6 elect committee has been very
good at over the past year
and of course it's not going to continue
because
Republicans are going to take the house
so the select committee is not going to
exist
they're going to close the committee but
here's the thing here's what they're
really good at this entire year
they've been really good at the trickle
the drip drip drip drip drip and what it
does is it keeps the news in that cycle
right because we got like a three minute
news cycle
like a three minute news cycle in this
country right now it's [ __ ]
ridiculous how fast the stories go come
and go
it it just it it's insanity
but they go by so fast
and the media misses most of it like the
important part like you know mocking
them the real headline
with these [ __ ] frauds the
Republicans
of course I'm talking about Republicans
um and and just just toxic masculinity
in general is a fraud
example is Andrew Tate trust me I'm
gonna go through this don't worry don't
worry I'm going to explain
what this is I don't even know why
Andrew Tate who who the [ __ ] is he now
this morning I made the thumbnail
um and I'm pretty proud of it actually
I think I did a pretty damn good job
usually Mr Sanchez makes our thumbnails
but he's been feeling under the weather
so I've been picking up the slack but I
think this morning the thumbnail was
very
um very appropriate now I didn't know
besides him being a [ __ ] Alpha cook
why Andrew Tate is famous I thought he's
he's just some [ __ ] [ __ ] that
talks into a microphone that a bunch of
trumped up white dudes
look at him yeah he's Tiff look at the
tattoo he got muscles and he smokes
cigars I think they think he's cool and
tough and [ __ ] I don't I don't know
now the video that he that he made again
this is all fraud it's all [ __ ]
him owning cars and him having all kinds
of money and all that that's all [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's nonsense
I mean hey Andrew Tate I'll give you my
[ __ ] email and you can send me your
tax returns and we'll look at them Jesus
Christ who is this gay I want the titles
to the 33 cars I want copies of the
titles Andrew Tate
I don't want a list of how many cars
you've rented to take pictures in front
of I want titles [ __ ]
that's right that's what he's done he
rents the car I'm telling you this is
what he does he rents the car just like
he rents the plane and he ain't just
enough money to rent the cars so he can
take all kinds of pictures he rents the
clothes probably he didn't own the
clothes he probably rents the clothes to
take pictures in front of the cars and
he changes clothes they drive a couple
places to get different scenery they
might even do it in front of a green
screen
so he can you know change the scenery
who [ __ ] knows
with these [ __ ] trumped up males
Jesus Christ
anyways they're frauds that's kind of
the basic Bare Bones of it
but they're all frauds
all of them
we found out in in the transcripts
yesterday that Cassidy Hutchison watched
Mark Meadows destroy
destroy documents in his fireplace in
the White House
and again I've been saying this for
months
the documents case has everything to do
with the January 6th Place they're the
same case it's the same exact case
that's why mayor Garland handed over
both cases
to Jack Smith
the war criminal prosecutor right
the guy who eats nails for Brett looks
like excuse me we did confirm with Karen
nicknipolo legal AF who knows Jack Smith
by the way she confirmed that he does
not eat nails for breakfast he just
looks like
he eats nails for breakfast
that guy that guy
um is gonna absolutely go for the
jugular
of the Cheeto dust q and honor
and he's completely [ __ ]
completely [ __ ] and the transcripts
that we will get today
is not only going to definitely upset
Grandpa Poopypants and probably he's
gonna have to stock up on more depends
now that Mar-A-Lago but here's the thing
um
it's also going to upset the right wing
my guess is that Elon has already
started to plan how to divert from the
ray Epps transcript
I okay
raps is not very significant in the
story
of January 6. the right wing has made
ray Epps
a significant part of the story
and again today when we when we see
these transcripts drop when we get to
know what the hell he said and what his
testimony was under oath
we're gonna find out that all that stuff
that the right wing trolls the Elon
scents the Andrew taints I think that's
what we're gonna call them
the the uh Andrew Andrew Tate
um followers the Andrew taints taints
they're the taints
I don't know seems appropriate
um all those [ __ ] that are in
your comments talking about laptops
they I would guess they're going to be
very pissed off about the testimony that
is going to drop today these transcripts
that's my guess now they're gonna be
like oh see
see Ray Epson and he did the and the
antifas and it was BLM and in the uh um
political prisoners they need to be set
for either Trump supporters they went to
the Capitol and committed violence and
they were arrested for no reason but it
was antifa I mean they're gonna say some
stupid [ __ ]
it's gonna be all backwards and turned
around
it's not gonna make any [ __ ] sense at
all
because I would imagine that the ray
Epps transcript
just absolutely is going to be
devastating to these right-wing trolls
that's my guess
I mean it's probably a pretty good guess
folks I'm just saying
I mean I'm not always right but I'm
almost always right
this rehab's thing is going to be
devastating to the right wing so we're
going to get these transcripts the other
ones wait wait just a minute let me see
if I can find the other
um the list of transcripts here because
I did not memorize them and again
um still recovering Christina Bob that's
an oh baby ooh baby Christina Bob's
testimony
the transcript from Christina but do you
remember Christina Bob
again if you want to know if you want to
know why the January 6 case and the
documents case
are the same [ __ ] case we'll look no
further than Christina Bob Christina Bob
worked for Department of Homeland
Security
she's a lawyer I mean sorta I use that
term loosely and really around Trump
you got to use the word lawyer Loosely
Jesus Christ half of the people who's
represented him have lost their [ __ ]
law license they're not even actual
lawyers anymore
but Christina Bob
um she's the one who was in the war room
with former attorney uh Rudy Giuliani uh
another former attorney in the future uh
John Eastman that [ __ ] is going
to go to prison for a long time
um and also Steve Bannon do you know who
that guy is yeah they were all in the
war room and Christina Bob was there
Christina bomb actually helped John
Eastman as the um that's what we say and
we'll see in the testimony I'm sure what
she testified to as far as the the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup memo
uh it was the it was for for Congress uh
congressmen and Senators to delay the
vote so that they could get the state
electors
send them back to the States buy enough
time for us to question the states that
way the states can re-vote or some [ __ ]
or we can have fake slate of electors
I mean this was the scheme they had many
schemes that they were trying to plot
for the coup because they knew these are
all [ __ ] right they knew this
and maybe we'll see this in Christina
Bob's
um testimony another another one and
significant is Stephen Miller
do you guys know who this [ __ ]
is
Stephen Miller
he is um
his testimony is going to drop today as
well it looks like uh also that Donald
Trump Jr so uh cokehead now I'm sure uh
Donald Trump Juniors is gonna be uh
fifth
one two three four Fifth Fifth Fifth I
mean it's gonna be the fifth all over
the boys
I'm sure that's exactly what it will be
and let's see who else who else was uh
oh uh Doug mastriano ooh
Doug mastriano was on the list son of a
[ __ ] you know Doug mastriano is
he is uh the the Mussolini of
Pennsylvania
remember he he got his ass whipped by
Shapiro
in the governor's race
I think that's the same Doug man Doug
mastriana was at January 6th he's an
interactionist that's one reason why he
lost I I don't know this looks pretty
significant
looks pretty significant as far as um
whose testimony is going to be dropping
today
but the the notable ones are Christina
Bob raps and Stephen Miller I think
Donald Trump Juniors will be significant
in that you will see
what that they are trying to hide
something
uh Donald Trump Jr probably didn't have
anything to do with the planning of the
coup and he just knew what the plan was
probably I mean Donald Trump Jr he can't
even [ __ ] do air quotes right
what makes you think they were going to
put him in charge of planning any kind
of [ __ ] coup can you imagine
can you imagine sitting around a table
and Junior's sitting there he cuts out a
line there's a line of coke
and he's talking about how exactly how
he wants the coup to go down you think
anyone's gonna [ __ ] listen to that
son of a [ __ ] Hales no
not a person at the table would listen
to that [ __ ] what's his
qualifications
anyways I mean other than he's
completely jealous of Hunter Biden
completely
butthurt about Hunter Biden and who
under Biden is are they what other news
do we have
um
the Santos thing
Jesus Christ now everyone resign is
trending again I keep telling you
[ __ ] you do not want him to
resign
and I know I know certain people in
places that you know I'm affiliated with
have called for him to resign he do not
want this [ __ ] to resign we
definitely definitely for political
discourse
and to move the ball forward to show
that all Republicans not just this one
are as much of a fraud as George Santos
is
he has to take office he can't I mean I
don't even know can you [ __ ] resign
from something you haven't you haven't
done yet
I mean he's on Capitol Hill tweeting
about going different places and
different museums
who knows he may be in front of a green
screen
pasting those museums and I don't know
this [ __ ] guy uh George Santos is
almost as much of a fraud
as a Nick Adams the alpha male
you know what I'm talking about on
Twitter it's [ __ ] gay
I I don't even know if George Santos
exists but apparently
um a prosecutor
uh in Nassau County I believe is that
where it's at uh let me let me let me
double check
I don't want to get this wrong here yes
and Donnelly
Nassau County New York is opening
criminal investigation
[Music]
uh apparently George Santos probably
more than likely committed crime while
he was trying to run for Congress and
probably something to do with the
Russian money that he took that might
have something to do with it
um
where he got the money who he paid and
how he paid I'm sure that George Santos
running as a republican this guy is not
gonna have an easy time that's why I
keep telling you you don't want him to
not you don't want him to not take
office why would we want this not to
play out
where because here's the thing the
reason why he's not going to resign let
me tell you
Kevin McCarthy is not gonna let George
Santos resign
until Kevin McCarthy has 218. no [ __ ]
way is Kevin McCarthy gonna let George
Santos resign they worked really hard to
get that fraud in Congress so Kevin
McCarthy could get to 218.
you think they're just gonna let him
walk now come on
you think you think Kevin McCarthy isn't
gross enough to let him take office and
because it's probably going to take at
least seven to ten days for Kevin
McCarthy to get to 218. who God knows
how many [ __ ] boats there's gonna
have to be
to get him there but he damn sure damn
sure needs George Santos
oh I forgot slow mode apparently uh hang
on just one second
the moderators the moderators uh see I
told you I told you this would happen
and I would um I'd forget some things
yeah let's see oh what do we want to do
we want to do 10 seconds the chat is
lighting up apparently
uh there's slow mode how's that how's
that in the chat
sorry about that
um so you guys look look the audience
here was growing fast not only are you
growing fast you guys are fully [ __ ]
engaged
with with this show and with the content
and really it's just it's just us
goofing and mocking
it really is uh hang on let me make sure
we get the moderators
okay I think I think um
[Laughter]
are we good are we good 10 is good 10 is
good
10 seconds 10 seconds you guys just like
this chat up it's like a [ __ ] pinball
machine
you remember the old pinball machines
some [ __ ]
I don't know I say something and you
guys are throwing stuff into the um into
the chat uh MJ says yes
must be she says good okay we're good to
go now now that we got the chat slowed
down just a bit
if you people then you and the
moderators can't keep up
with all the comments they're trying to
watch they're trying to respond they're
trying to react to you guys everyone's
trying to everyone engages in this show
highly
uh rather you're on YouTube which is the
the probably the most highly engaged
chat uh Facebook is also there's a ton
of people over there twitch is another
one they're all a little different
though like the chats for the show are a
little different
but the live chat on YouTube is um is
the one that really gets the boards
litten up so
um what was I talking about
something about Republicans being frauds
I'm sure
before I am had to slow down here for
the Monterey oh yes oh yes George Santos
and Kevin McCarthy needs him to get to
218. that's what we were that's what we
were having a conversation about so
that's that's the magic number for Kevin
McCarthy to be speaker of the house now
here's the thing Kevin McCarthy is the
only one now while he is the closest to
218 and watching there's there's not any
other person in Washington that's going
to get closer to 218 than Kevin McCarthy
we're gonna have a Kevin McCarthy
speakership I'm sure of it it's just a
matter again like I said before how much
of the speaker the office of the speaker
that he's going to trade away to his
caucus here's what I mean
um he's gonna have to make promises that
he either can't keep one or he's he's
not gonna want to keep two
or that really honestly in the in the
end and the grand scheme of things it's
kind of a you know be careful what you
wish for type thing when he hands over
power to his caucus in other words
they're going to be able to tell him
what the [ __ ] to do and when the [ __ ] to
do it
and what not to do really that's the
most important thing like how to not
govern
how do they they don't want to govern
they don't know how to govern
this is why this Republican uh House of
Representatives is going to be an
absolute utter failure
Bank on it
for sure trust me on this doubt me if
you will but this Republican Congress is
going to be an absolute utter disaster
it's not going to go well for the
Republicans right
we know this
we know they suck at governing because
they don't know how to do it
so it only makes sense
it only makes sense that we do not I
know I know I know you're gonna say Tony
you're out of your mind Santos is a
fraud he may be a criminal
we want him but what Republican isn't at
this point
what are you talking about what Republic
if if you're calling for Santos to
resign because he's a fraud and a
possible criminal we should call for
every single person that has an R next
to their name to resign no matter what
office they hold whether it's congress
senate
[ __ ] all the way down to the dog
catchers
I'm just saying
and I I know I know I know I know you
don't want Santos
to [ __ ] all over
the office
of a congressperson by taking office and
going to the floor and telling lies
but listen
they do it every day folks go watch
C-SPAN they do it every [ __ ]
day
all of them they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care about [ __ ] lies and
telling you lies and gaslighting you
they don't give a [ __ ]
why why why are we so excited
about George Santos going to the floor
and telling the same old [ __ ]
Republican lies
I'm I'm here for it
frankly
I want the tape of him standing on the
floor this [ __ ] fraud
even they're calling him a fraud I mean
other than Kevin McCarthy Kevin McCarthy
ain't gonna say [ __ ] about this guy
until he gets to 218. and then he's
gonna [ __ ] all over Santos oh my God
there's going to be Ethics Committee
there oh man they're gonna make a big
deal
out of how this guy we're I mean they're
gonna make an example of him
of how
how you don't Gaslight how you don't be
a fraud okay Santos you're supposed to
do it the old way
you know like Trump did it 2016 and his
entire presidency in 2020 and he's still
doing it for 2024
it's a complete utter fraud a complete
[ __ ] grift come on Santos
don't you know is that is that his name
you think
there's a clip somewhere where he's
talking about um
and and I don't even know if these
stories are real he's talking about his
his grandma being in the Holocaust and
they didn't take her Jewish name
something like that so I don't know what
Santos is his real [ __ ] name I have
no idea
I mean he George may not even I don't
know I have no idea but again I don't
give a [ __ ]
I don't care
I want him to take office I want him to
vote I want Kevin McCarthy to have to
have that [ __ ] fraud to get to 218
after days and days and days of bringing
votes to the floor when he can't get
there
they suck at this folks
and we're probably gonna see more of how
they suck at things I mean why do you
think their coup attempt didn't work
they're [ __ ] worthless
they really are [ __ ] worthless
and the prime example is gonna be George
going to the floor
and again spewing the same Republican
lies it's not going to be anything new
from Santos when he goes to the floor of
the house
and he starts to speak into a microphone
it's going to be the same [ __ ] that
Marjorie Taylor green says Andy bigs
that [ __ ] bigot
Paul go any of them
any of them
Kevin McCarthy that go to the floor and
lie
to the American people and put it on the
record Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan Matt Getz Lauren Bobo the Clown
bobert come on
George Santos fits right in
why why so excited for him to resign
that's just my question
I don't know maybe I'm off my rocker
oh
yeah George Santos needs to resign he
hasn't even taken the seat yet and Kevin
McCarthy hasn't used him for the 218 I'm
telling you I almost bet that we're
gonna have a situation where
George Santos is the 218. what do you
think
I'm almost sure of it I'm almost sure of
it as sure as I am and we're going to be
right back
right after this break don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
we're on slow mode
[Music]
yes love the chat
get excited in the chat the moderators
can't keep up so we put it on 10 seconds
so if you're in on the YouTube chat
you're gonna have a 10 second slow I
don't know what the [ __ ] that means
really honestly
and that means that you can't it you can
only put a message in the chat like
every 10 seconds or something is that
what that means I don't know I don't
know but the moderators uh love the slow
mode uh Margie says slow mode is our
friend so we will we will keep it on
someone and and the last few days
um I've remembered
to do it when I make the broadcast uh
and I prepare the broadcast but today I
I forget you ever forget I forgot I told
him I'd do it too I told the moderators
this I said Hey listen I'm going to
forget this Amber now and again I'm
gonna try to make it a habit but I'm
going to forget so uh give the
moderators some love in the chat they're
the best monitors moderators in the
world
along with moderating the best audience
in the world which is you the listeners
out there
it is a fact is
oh you [ __ ] talking about 10 seconds
um
oh Jesus Christ George Santos uh
Caitlyn's pointing out apparently has
he lied about having a cancerous brain
tumor also Jesus Christ what hasn't this
guy lied about
that serious it's [ __ ] gay what the
[ __ ]
there's there's some tweets out there
and these [ __ ] are real where he's
talking about how his mom died uh in the
terrorist attack on 9 11. and then like
I don't know 15 years later he's talking
about how his mom died again so he has
more than one mom or I I'm not really
sure he's probably lying
um
oh there's a video okay there's a video
of this [ __ ] all right well we're gonna
get to videos here
for damn sure because I got the video of
um Andrew Tate excuse me
um the alpha cook video
of Andrew tank the small dick energy
Andrew
Andrew Tate I he initiated this little
tiff
with uh Greta
I I think I think we confirmed yesterday
in the chat she's 19. so he he initiates
this fight
this this internet virtual Twitter
battle
with Greta thundberg
the climate activist
the teenaged climate activists and
um she immediately owns him okay almost
immediately
as soon as she sees the Tweet she she
owns him of course because you know
she's got a [ __ ] brain so you know
it's easy to come back on these Alpha
cuts
but it took him almost all day
to make a video where he shows the uh
the the the people watching the video
his nipple
I'm not kidding that's that's the
thumbnail so I took the if you look at
the thumbnail today that is the actual
[ __ ] screenshot when he he opens up
his robe
to show the camera his nipple
it's [ __ ] weird it's weird as [ __ ]
it's some weird [ __ ] [ __ ] but that's
where I I took that's the part where I
took the screen grab
for the thumbnail for the small dick
energy thumbnail
and and of course almost immediately the
Twitter lights up when he posts this
video
and small dick Energy starts to trend
God damn
how how would that how would that make
you feel
if you're when you come back to Twitter
from your Hiatus because you're a pile
of [ __ ] garbage
and you can't even keep your Twitter
account oh Jesus Christ I say some crazy
[ __ ] on Twitter how the [ __ ] can't these
people keep their Twitter account open
anyways the point is this
Elon gives him back his account his
Twitter account now if you remember Gabe
Sanchez pointed out
that when when Andrew take got his
Twitter account back from Elon
Andrew Tate took a a video of him on a
plane
smoking a cigar
acting like he's drinking uh whiskey out
of a glass when the whiskey bottle
that's sitting on the table has not been
opened because he can't open the whiskey
bottle he'd have to pay for it
okay you can't open the whiskey bottle
he'd have to [ __ ] pay for it
just like he'd have to pay for a plane
twice
once for the original video and then
again to go visit Elon in person because
that's what he said in the Tweet when he
tweeted out himself flying on a plane he
said I'm going to personally thank Elon
well he wasn't because that video was
taken months earlier from when he rented
the plane
and he took several videos from several
different positions
several different outfits that he rented
so that way it looked like he had plenty
of
footage
so that way he could make these plane
videos make it look like he's flying all
the time have you guys said what the
[ __ ] is that um I think it's a Netflix
series
uh where this this guy
um tricks these women in Europe
right he tricks them into thinking he's
some kind of Rich Diamond billionaire or
some [ __ ] I don't know I don't know have
you seen this what the hell is that
called I watched it it's it's
interesting as [ __ ]
um it shows you exactly the method that
Andrew Tate is using to convince his
supporters that he's rich
and then an influencer and he's got all
these 33 cars and that's how you know
that it's all [ __ ]
it's what he that's that's how he
started the [ __ ] with with uh Greta is
he wanted her email so he could send
small dick pics I mean uh a list
excuse me a list of his 33 cars
that he does not own that he's taken
pictures with when he when he rents them
holy [ __ ] uh yeah oh yeah tender guy
tender swindler that's it
several people have it in here that's it
that's the one
that's the one he that's what he is
oh he's the he's the alpha cuck swindler
uh Andrew Tate is the alpha [ __ ]
swindler because he's you know he's
really he's swindling all these Alpha
cuts out there you know these Elon samps
the trumped up white dudes and then they
love him
you know this toxic masculinity [ __ ] you
know he really leans into it
uh he if someone says he looks black
I mean he may be I don't know I have no
idea what Andrew Tate's race is I don't
think it really [ __ ] matters to be
quite honest with you
as as stupid as he is and
it's hard to look past his dumb [ __ ]
and to even start having a conversation
about what race he is because I'll tell
you this morning this morning when I was
doing the thumbnail I was looking for a
picture
of Andrew Tate so I went to Google
Images to see what pictures were out
there of this guy
this guy is taking many different
transformations in his life and in his
internet swindling career as
Angela points out this is tender
swindler so he's the alpha cut swindler
but in his swindling career that Andrew
Tate has had he's had several different
looks
several different phases of his
influence but I I there on Google when
you Google this [ __ ] I don't
know if you have he probably shouldn't
but if you do it says
it says
uh American British kickboxer
is what is what he's titled
so I I guess that's his claim
to fame other than his [ __ ]
ridiculous showing of his nipples
um is that uh he's an American British
kickboxer I don't know I don't even know
what that is is there like a specific
type of kickboxing that's American
British or is he American and British I
don't know don't know don't really give
a [ __ ] but let's do this because there
are some videos that I want to show so
let's
go to the countdown because we got the
[ __ ] list Roundup where we round up all
the Tweety tweets and 20 trendy Trends
why they still exist start that
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the Tony Michaels
podcast we've reached the part of the
show where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and trendy trends of the day
um someone pointed out the Matrix
this guy talks about the Matrix we were
we were watching a video yesterday where
he's talking about the majors I think he
thinks the movie's real so I think he
thinks the Matrix of movies are our
docu-series or some [ __ ]
I I have no idea what the [ __ ] that even
means
um someone says American British
question mark yeah that's what it says
go Googling
we Google Andrew Tate
it says American British kickboxer some
[ __ ] like that I don't know
I don't know
I know he looks like he'd get his
[ __ ] ass stomped in
to me
so maybe he's
maybe he's famous for getting
his ass kicked I don't know I really
don't
I don't know if he's a amateur
professional I have no idea that's just
what it says
maybe he paid Google
to have that I mean he pays and rents
everything else
that's what this small dick energy
thing's about
uh so let's go let's do this first
because apparently there is a video
there is a video of George Santos
claiming he has a brain tumor
here it is
see if we can pull it up here
this is what is this on is this on some
kind of weird ass
podcast or some [ __ ]
episode
you see here and it says you know let's
zoom in
it says episode 128.
he's on a podcast here with um
I don't know who these guys are is that
Baked Alaska is that who that guy is
this guy over here does Andrew that is I
mean it looks like it I'm not really
sure
is that who that is
[ __ ] I don't know bacon Alaska you know
he's the one that he's an
insurrectionist he's the one that got uh
sentenced to prison
and um
and I don't know if this is him over
here but I mean it kind of they all kind
of look the same don't they
um but this guy here
if this is Baked Alaska he even tweeted
I went I'm gonna go to prison for an nft
salesman
you're really pissed off
um
but this post it says three years ago he
claimed he had a brain tumor and
received chemo so this is holy [ __ ] so
wait a second
this is March 30th of 2020. so this is
before this is right this is right at
the start of the pandemic that may be
why it's called the corona story because
you know that was kind of the joke when
the when the coronavirus started up
covet started up
Hmm this is interesting
of course again I have not watched this
clip it's only 26 seconds long Caitlyn
sent it to me here and and we're gonna
watch him lie
about getting a having a brain tumor I
guess let's let's let's listen here see
if we can smoke this out oh look I have
an immunodeficiency and I also have
acute chronic bronchitis uh you know I I
also battled a a brain tumor a couple of
years ago and I had radiation done which
really really lowers your immunity in
general radiation isn't a game right uh
and I'm susceptible to cancer it's in my
DNA right so I'm not I'm not gonna say
I'm the healthiest person out there but
I'm not one of the most healthiest
oh [ __ ] so yeah so
um
this guy apparently
um had cancer of the empty space in
between his ears
um what the [ __ ]
people are pointing that out in the chat
don't you have to have brains to have
brain cancer this [ __ ] guy man this
guy is the most Republican of all
Republicans why are they so pissed off
at George Santos they should they should
be excited about this guy frankly you
should be like oh we love this dude he
is the most Republican Republican that
has ever been elected to the Republican
Congress
I mean I mean you want to talk about
[ __ ] lies let me tell you who does it
best Donald Trump doesn't hold a candle
to the lies that George Santos they you
know what
you know what I'm I'm just thinking this
right now write out loud as as we're
sitting here on the show what George
Santos should do
is he should take office give Kevin
McCarthy his 218 and announce his run
for president in 2024 of the Republican
party that's what George Santos should
do I mean think about it it's it's it's
the most obvious thing that a republican
would do
I mean he's under criminal investigation
now apparently so if he would win
if he would if he would run it would
make him immune from anything and
everything I mean isn't that how
Republicans believe as long as long as
you say you're running from president
they can't prosecute you for anything
I mean I'm sure that the same brain that
George Santos says he had cancer on I
bet that brain
if he thinks hard enough would actually
declassify documents this is a
prerequisite
you have to have that magic power that
ability to be a republican nominee and a
Republican president you have to be able
to declassify things with your brain
so I don't know I mean I'm I'm saying
this might be a great career move if
George Santos hears me
George buddy listen give Kevin the 218
and then announce your run for president
of the United States as the nominee for
the Republican party in 2024. that's
what you should do buddy I think you got
a great future ahead of you in the
Republican Party
you have a great future ahead of you you
really do George you really do this is
[ __ ] crazy
oh what the [ __ ] oh this tweet gets
better nope we're going back to it look
at this [ __ ] this is getting better here
um so Tyler points out oh my God this is
a tweet
this is this [ __ ] real
no way
no way right
it says Roger has here says two years
ago George Santos claimed to be half
black
I mean maybe I don't know but listen if
you believe anything that a republican
says especially George Santos whoosh
okay so and again this is this is the
Republican way
um he this is from 7 3 20 20. so this is
um uh you know roughly three months
just a few days over three months after
his little brain tumor talk here
[Laughter]
Alley Cat ah you're on to me is Tony
still drunk from an all-nighter no I I
went to sleep I went to sleep
I'm not doing all nighter geez Louise
you'd take me as come on
I'm not in my 20s anymore
okay let's get back to the business here
George Santos says uh Martin Luther King
MLK did not die for us to go back to
segregation as a biracial person I Stand
Tall against segregation of any kind
this so-called black Anthem is the most
divisive thing I've ever seen we are
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
it's it's it's I don't think he's saying
he's black here but let's let's let's
continue down this this whole let's see
okay so he does he responds he responds
to the person asking
what two races you are Caucasian and
black
so he he did claim right here this is
seven six so this is three days after
his original tweet
Caucasian and black
so he did he did tweet that he was black
oh my God what in the actual [ __ ] is
going on
George man dude
and then he ran for congress how in the
[ __ ]
how in the [ __ ]
did Democrats lose New York's third with
this guy being the goddamn nominee on
the Republican side how the [ __ ] did we
let this one slide
see and that's why I'm telling you he
needs to take office
we have to know the consequences of us
not paying attention
to some of these Republican frauds you
remember Majewski uh we did we did some
extensive [ __ ] on Majewski um Gabe
Sanchez even did a what was that you can
go watch the what was that on the Midas
touch network of Majewski
the what was that the Gabe Sanchez did
and this guy's a [ __ ] fraud
um he was another one that was a a total
total [ __ ] liar lied about his
service lied about where he was
you know just complete Stolen Valor from
J.R Majewski
remember his pronouns were dumb and [ __ ]
I don't know
these guys but apparently George Santos
claims he's half black and he had a
brain oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh Brandon wolf uh has it here
um let me show you
he may be Blackish
if you want to you know he was Jewish
maybe he's Black-ish oh [ __ ] me running
good Lord
oh the internet
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the internet
the internet okay let's get back to some
serious business here about George
Santos because there is actual news
about this guy and the the D.A
um the district attorney in Nassau
County is going to be opening a criminal
investigation
into this into this person whoever this
George Santos is
see if I can find the tweet
maybe maybe not
oh and there it is okay here is um
here's the resign tab
um everyone's got resign trending uh
Even Adam kinsinger called for him to
resign the [ __ ] out of here Adam
kinzinger listen now that the January
6th select committee is over and here it
is here's Adam kinzinger's resign resign
because George Santos was posing in a
picture
um at the Merchant Marine Academy in
Kings Point
and he's talking about how he's gonna go
to Congress and Adam can just says
resign listen now that the January 6
select committee is over can we all
agree [ __ ] Adam kinzinger and fuckless
Janie can we do that can we all
collectively do that that's what I want
to do
um I've been telling you for a long time
you definitely do not want to make
kinsinger and especially Liz Cheney
Heroes here they're not [ __ ] Heroes
they just did the bare minimum
which was their job
their job was to protect the
Constitution and protect your vote they
did their job
bare minimum type [ __ ] for a congress
person okay doesn't matter if it's
Democrat or Republican
so I'm just saying okay
um here let's see if I can find this uh
tweet about how he's under investigation
there it is Hugo has it and this is out
of the New York AP Hugo's tweet at
quoting uh County Prosecutors in New
York are investigating GOP U.S rep elect
George Santos after lying about his
background or his lies about his
background emerge
um lies about anything he's ever said
it feels like to me
that George Santos is a little
pathological
right like maybe he does kind of believe
some of this [ __ ]
and then when he needs to say something
else and say another lie maybe he feels
that too I don't know I have no idea
I couldn't say oh so Hugo's got the
story there on George Santos so it looks
like there's gonna be
an actual criminal investigation which
will probably result in a federal
prosecution and conviction
um especially around the 700 Grand
that he apparently gave to his own
campaign
The Story Goes that he was making about
40 or 50
000 a year and then all of a sudden he
ran into a I don't know a Russian or
something where he can make and several
million dollars a year and then he gave
his campaign 700 grand
um if you go to let's see if I can find
this
Mueller she wrote I believe had it Ty
Ross Ty's probably here I don't know if
she's in the chat today or not now Ty
did a story on it as well I think or was
going to do a story on it
um but Mueller she wrote had a thread
that I was reading the other day about
this yes I was reading Mueller she wrote
threads they're great threads by the way
uh
okay let's go to the George Santos is a
fraud thread
she tweets a lot so it takes me a minute
to find this
um oh by the way
I just saw this in her thread
let's go to Muir she wrote's page here
um
there is news that Jamie Raskin
actually does have cancer he's got a
diagnosis
um so Jamie ranskin is going to be
treated for lymphoma
um so I hope hope Jamie uh you know
Congressman Raskin makes it through uh
unfazed I know it probably be a
difficult treatment
um he put out a statement the other day
basically saying that he had lymphoma
this type of lymphoma and that it is
treatable
and that he's going to do the treatment
and he plans on recovering as soon as
possible so I I would imagine Jamie
we're asking you talk about a tough
[ __ ] man
you talk about one tough son of a [ __ ]
the guy
facing personal tragedy
and um still
upholding his oath and and his job for
his constituents and for the country
is absolutely
um mind-bending when you think about
what had happened to his child
um and how he was able to make sure he
still did his duty for his country and
for his office
he's he's a bad [ __ ] folks he's
a bad [ __ ] so I feel sorry for
the cancer if you want to know the truth
um
it's the last person I'd want to [ __ ]
with if I was cancer oh here's another
hat hell hang on hang on a minute hang
on a minute we got another uh
George Santos clip yeah see I knew I
could count on I knew I could count on
Allison Allison thank you today for
helping produce the show with yours with
your timeline
um she says no [ __ ] oh my God so
Republicans against trumpism the account
uh it looks like they posted this video
it's got one million views now and this
is this this is George Santos and he's
at seatpac
um listen to what he had to say
about Moscow see if you can figure out
why they're doing in the criminal
investigation on this guy listen I've
been to Moscow many times during my
career I mean you stay at the St Regis
on the red square right off the red
square I've been to Moscow many times
during my career I mean you stay at the
St Regis on the red square right off the
red square I've been to Moscow many
times sorry I didn't mean to play it so
many times but he's been to Moscow so
many times that uh you know I figured we
might as well play it a couple times so
um Allison uh thank you for the uh
and for the production of today's show
oh mange we're just going to go down our
timeline maybe here I'm still trying to
look for this thread that she had on
Santos
[Music]
um
because she's got a bunch of she's got a
bunch of Russians oh wait she's got some
more news uh oh I will go back to that
where is it where is it where is it I'm
looking for this thread
that she had about George Santos of
course that um oh here we go
here we go
here we go here it is I think this is
the one thread for those asking where
liar George Santos got the money to run
his campaign the size of a portion of it
came from a man named
in Trader and
seems appropriate I don't know and tater
and tater tot I guess I don't know the
name sounds familiar folks who listen to
OG Mueller she wrote podcast that's
because it they're Russian
and she talks about Michael Cohen here
um she talks about how Cohen
um they they got 250 000 into Trump's
inaugural campaign
um and and again the doj has accused
weitzelberg a fraud and money laundering
sees 90 million and 90 million dollar
yacht she goes on to say
um now
it really gets hairy when Mitch
McConnell gets involved of course Mitch
McConnell is involved in everything
because Mitch McConnell was trying to
get an aluminum plant in Kentucky now
you can see here he was lobbying for
that and he was trying to get uh like
Dara potska and he's trying to get the
darapaska regime
um get their sanctions taken down so
that way Dara posca could fund an
aluminum plant in Kentucky for Mitch
McConnell you know Russian money runs
deep in the Republican party they really
love it
um and he McConnell lobbied to live
sanctions
he wanted to fund this Factory now
mnuchin even protected Trump she goes on
from mandatory presidential tax audits
hmm I wonder what's going to be in the
tax returns
but
um again she says at the very end of
course she sources all this stuff
so no one in my house is surprised that
the straw candidate meaning George
Santos
was partly funded and by sanctioned
Russian oligarchs tied to Trump
not surprising I mean it's the
Republican way nowadays so I'll I'll um
Let me let me retweet this
thread boom
thank you Allison for your for your
thread and you can go read the thread
and check out the sources The Source
material from Mother Jones The Daily
Beast in New York Times
on the back story of possibly where
George Santos is probably gonna go to a
federal penitentiary I'm just saying
whoosh did you know that it is illegal I
don't know if you know this did you know
is it legal to put foreign money
into a campaign there was a guy
who
um was one of Rand Paul's and Ron Paul's
um he was on their campaigns
presidential campaigns he also was part
of the Iowa Republican party he's
actually going to go to prison uh Donald
Trump uh pardoned him
and then he's going to prison four uh
Donald Trump because he put money into
Donald Trump's campaign foreign money
kind of pointing how that works it's
illegal it's illegal
you cannot have foreign money
influencing
our national politics
that's why it's illegal it's called
buying influence and you know stuff like
that it gets to be corrupt
you know the Republican way
so um that's why I'm not I do not want
George Santos to resign I want the guy
to take office I want him to be number
218.
to make Kevin McCarthy the speaker that
will be their [ __ ] Legacy folks that
will be Kevin McCarthy's entire Legacy
of his speakership got it
George Santos had to get him to 218.
they had to keep him as a congressperson
they had to swear that [ __ ] fraud in
they had to stomach him for weeks on end
until finally Kevin McCarthy got to 218
and we will pin this badge
just like the fraudulent one that
Herschel Walker flash seat the fraud
thing is a pattern
we will pin this fraudulent badge to
their chest and make them own it forever
and ever and ever and ever and ever and
ever never let Kevin McCarthy forget
that it took George Santos a complete
utter fraud
to get him to his speakership okay
you know a lot of people are comparing
on the internet before I move on to this
Andrew Tate thing I got we gotta do this
video we watched the video that we we
we did the Tweet yesterday
uh where he was tweeting at Greta
and wanting her email so he could email
her dick pics or list of cars or
something I don't know
and then she owned him immediately
there's a video of him responding so we
gotta get to that but there are people
comparing
George Santos to Al Franken listen this
is the dumbest stupid [ __ ] that we do
as as liberals okay this is the
stupidest [ __ ] thing this is the
dumbest [ __ ] it's not advisable
why in the [ __ ]
is anyone
comparing Al Franken
to George Santos I mean I know I know
what you're saying is that like oh well
Al Franken had to resign over a staged
picture
that that was released on the internet
as if it wasn't staged
it's the picture of him grabbing a
woman's breast that photographer even
said it was all set up
it was staged
they want a USO tour
the point is this is that stop comparing
Al Franken to George Santos you dumb
[ __ ] stop it
listen
when you are trying to form a national
narrative and National messaging the
last thing you want to do the last thing
you want to do
is to rope in a Democrat a very
effective one who could more than likely
be
a United States Senator again
okay
or a governor a vice president Al
Franken could do just about anything he
wanted to in politics because he's smart
he knows policy the guy is very very
very good at policy and I don't know if
you watch clips of Al Frank and
absolutely destroy people when he was on
Senate committees but he's very good at
that too
he's a comedian he's a Wordsmith for
crying out loud
that's what the guy does
he's done it his whole life
is work through performance with words
you don't think he's gonna cut through
Republicans like a hot knife through
styrofoam and you [ __ ] are comparing
the situation that he was into George
Santos I understand that he had to
resign I get it but stop doing that stop
it that's not you do not want to deflect
off George Santos to Al Franken that's
why I keep telling you what you want to
do is get George Santos in office get
him in front of a microphone let him
tell the old Republican lies and then
tie those Republican lies to every
[ __ ] Republican and show how much of
a fraud
their entire America First Nazi party is
stop with the Democrat [ __ ] especially
someone like Al Franken
okay that's not that's not how you do a
narrative that's not how you do
messaging frankly
no pun intended
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] I don't know I'm just trying to
give a master class here I guess
and messaging why do you think I just
beat up on them all day every day
all day every day her day we don't go
try to tie the situation
um and and and our national narrative
this is what the media does right this
is the stupid [ __ ] that the media does
first thing the media thinks is oh well
how is George Santos being in complete
utter fraud bad for Democrats what what
and they're like well let's point out
let's point out a situation that's not
even close to the same Al Franken and
then let the right run with it that that
Al franken's being compared to Santos
you are stupid [ __ ] stop doing
that
that's why I keep telling that's why
listen yesterday we played the [ __ ]
clip a Tulsi gabbard
taking the words right out of my mouth
from that morning before I said that
morning what we want is George Santos to
get on the floor of the house and tell
lies the old tropes and Republican lies
that way everyone in this country knows
he's complete utter fraud they already
know it everyone's seen it it's right
out in the open he's a [ __ ] liar and
he's telling the old same Republican
lies that's what we want that is the
tape we want that is the proof we want
we want Kevin McCarthy to need him
to get to 218 this is what we want you
do not want people running around
talking about George Santos having Al
Franken on their mind
that is not how you do messaging that is
not how you do a national narrative it's
not
okay
it's not advisable if you want to win
you want you want you want school to
start for children at three instead of
five do you want to make sure that
Americans do not go broke because of
medical bills do you want that do you
want to make sure that college is
Affordable for every [ __ ]
and you have to go broke to get a
[ __ ] degree and get a decent career
which will be broke because you got to
pay back all that [ __ ] money with
high interest
do you want that
do you want decent [ __ ] wages do you
want decent [ __ ] labor laws do you
want labor
to have a chance in this country
when fighting corporations well look you
gotta win elections to do that [ __ ]
and to win elections you got to play
politics you gotta politicize everything
all of it the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] and
caboodle including George Santos and the
best idea I got is not
is not to tie him to Al Franken
[ __ ] wrong with you sorry
figured I'd set everything straight
there on what not to do
maybe it'll help on what to do
make every Republican
George Santos okay that's what you do
it's what you do okay let's move on to
this Andrew Tate video
I know you're dying to see it
holy moly again I don't know if you
folks know who the [ __ ] Andrew Tate is
um he he goes on a lot of shows he says
a lot of toxic masculinity [ __ ] he's
he's really [ __ ] fragile he's a
snowflake he gets offended by everything
I mean a woman sneezes and he's [ __ ]
offended right there is no [ __ ] more
offended person in this country
then right wing trumped up [ __ ] males
they're just they're the most offended
people you've ever met in your entire
[ __ ] life
the weakest of the week
I mean can't even can't even muster
enough brain cells to scrape together to
come up with an original idea
they think they live in the madman movie
type [ __ ]
really [ __ ] weird stuff that they
think this is how the world works
but again it's this fraud thing they're
making this [ __ ] up they're trying to
live in an alternate reality right the
delusion is great ignorance is bliss
type [ __ ] right
well Andrew Tate definitely has an
ignorance is bliss
type attitude again
all this [ __ ] about 33 fast cars and
expensive houses and private planes and
how much money
he he [ __ ] makes that's all [ __ ]
it's all a fraud
it's a [ __ ] fraud
he rents those cars to take pictures
with them he probably rents the clothes
that he's wearing
just saying
so let's go to the uh the video clip
it's very important
um and it's you know I I we're gonna
mock him
but here's the thing because you want to
know what this has to do with a national
narrative folks I'm telling you
I know it doesn't feel like it but
there's a high percentage
we used to have fake game in the chat
you remember fake Gabe remember this guy
we had to get rid of him
poor fake gave me he had to be banned
because he was causing all kinds of [ __ ]
he just wouldn't come here and just type
in the Trump copy machine
right he wouldn't just type in the same
old [ __ ] [ __ ] he had to [ __ ]
cause trouble
and the mods do not put up with that
the minds do not put up with that and I
just
try them they won't put up with your
[ __ ]
um and then again I the mods are the
ones who run the chat so
careful they will bounce you
um and
someone says they miss fake Gabe I mean
you know to some degree I miss his
comments I wish we had another person
that would you know type in comments
like he did
but there is no more
embodiment
of fake Gabe than this stupid
[ __ ]
this cigar smoke I bet I bet he when
he's off camera he's like
cars though
you hurt me so bad now
if you notice here
he's sitting at a table smoking a cigar
in in a robe
um so you're thinking he's naked and
he's got a leather chair which oh boy
that's definitely got to be expensive
and he's sitting against wood paneling
now this is probably all a [ __ ] setup
right
that I bet those walls are not real
I I bet it's a fraud
100 percent
he built those panels as a set you know
I got I got [ __ ] in the background here
right this is all this is all [ __ ]
behind me that I got
here let me show you let me pull it up
on the screen see all this [ __ ] behind
me I I don't have a green screen right
so I shed all this stuff up like the
nugs not drugs there's the mega there's
the George Carlin books there's a plant
there's a [ __ ] em hat there's some
sunglasses there's an old an older
microphone I used to use and there's so
there's another there's a microphone
right here type thing I got a hat over
here I got a lock Em Up Banner which you
can get at store.d Tony michaels.com you
get a lock Em Up brand Banner
store not the Tony michaels.com I got
the TV that I used to play news on there
but people get distracted so I just put
our our podcast art we've got a uh um
stay pissed mug here
so there's all kinds of stuff in the
background right
it's a set you're you're displaying
things you're making it interesting
that's what this is
these wood panels because he thinks it
makes him look expensive
because of all his internet audience
needs to think that he's Rich that if
they do not believe he's Rich he's
[ __ ] and this is his entire internet
personality
that he's rich and it's easy to be rich
is what he says apparently that's when I
Googled him this morning to find an
image that's what I found out
um
but this video here is a direct response
to uh Greta's um
tweet
let me find it
here is here's Greta's uh no that's the
video that that's the actual video than
me here we go
um so this is the tweet that he
originally sent to Greta he said hello
Coretta I have 33 cars now we went
through this yesterday but I want to
make sure the audience that wasn't here
yesterday gets a taste of this gets a
whiff of this [ __ ]
I have 33 cars you know that's a lie
because he typed it
uh he definitely is George Santos in
here can we can we make that Santos this
is a Santos I have 33 cars
okay
listen if you're if you're counting if
you have 33 cars if you actually own 33
cars
and you're counting them and then you
have to type it in on Twitter
you don't actually own 33 cars
and he goes on to talk about a couple of
the cars that he has a Bugatti two
Ferraris
and he said this is just a start
please he's asking a a climate activist
a teenaged climate actor I think she's
19. soon to be 20.
um to provide her email address so he
can send a complete list of his car
collection
which is just pictures that he's
collected of cars that he's rented and
stood next to
taking a picture is proof that he rented
them and stood next to them
um and their respective enormous
emissions of course here is one of these
this is one of these staged pictures
where he rented a Bugatti
and he pulled it into a gas station and
he's appearing to put gas in it
and it's just enough gas to get to a few
more locations to take a few more
pictures and then get that [ __ ] back
where he rented it from okay
so that's that's the um that's the Tweet
he sent out he picked this fight
he told her hello
Greta hello and then of course this is
her almost immediate response let me
check yeah this is almost her immediate
response
to dumb [ __ ] here as soon as she opened
up her notifications and noticed this
this tag of her I'm sure she typed this
out almost immediately she said yes
please do enlighten me email me at small
dickenergy at getalife.com
of course
obviously this is not a real email
it's telling him
that he has a small dick and to get a
life stop tagging her about his [ __ ]
fraudulent 33 car collection
now
you would think that a guy
who is well versed at the internet would
understand that he just got [ __ ]
owned
right you would think
an influencer quote
would understand that a teenaged climate
activist just dunked him in the
[ __ ] garbage
with her quote tweet
he did not he did not understand this he
thought he got her good
and then he proceeds to make a video
which is even more cringe
than the the [ __ ] tweet he sent out
where he was picking a fight with her
over what is his in his imaginary car
collection so he quote tweets
the small dick energy at getalife.com
tweet I know this is [ __ ] crazy
oh God I can't believe we have to go
through this
storyline to get to this weird ass video
but this is what we gotta do because hey
here's the thing he thinks it's [ __ ]
cute
he thinks it's cute to own a lib
the same reason why Elon Musk burnt 44
billion dollars on Twitter and is
burning 30 billion dollars and really
it's adding up to be almost 300 billion
dollars if you put it all together
probably on how much value he's lost
Tesla and tank Tesla and Twitter they're
both piles of [ __ ] now
all to own the libs does this sound
familiar this is their entire
personality set
the entirety of it
they cannot help but run face first into
the wall while they're trying to own the
libs
so he makes this video it takes him
hours hours to come up with this two
minute video
God knows how many clips of this this
dumb [ __ ] did
but here's his tweet
thank you for confirming via your email
address that that you have a small penis
Greta thundberg
the world was curious and I do agree you
should get a life oh sick burn Andrew
you are such a dummy
anyone reading her tweet knows she's
talking about his dick and his life
and of course he's like I'd ribber your
glue what bounces off me sticks to you
literally it is an I'm rubber your glue
come back what the [ __ ] and the video is
even more on rubber your glue
even more
why does this matter why it's the same
reason why the Kanye West [ __ ] mattered
okay
we have to mock them and someone says
that standard error says so dumb yes it
is [ __ ] ridiculous
dumbest [ __ ] I've seen in a while I mean
three or four days
three or four days dumbest [ __ ] I've
seen bar none
but listen
if you go watch Steve bannon's Trader TV
News Network the my pillow Nazi his
[ __ ] his Trader News Network
Tucker Carlson Show Jesus Christ I
showed you Tulsi gabbard the other day
taking the words right out of my mouth
and not wanting that to be the narrative
which we're gonna make at the narrative
he's gonna be a congressman he's gonna
vote for Kevin McCarthy and we're going
to hold him to it
but every single one of them do videos
just like this just like this I'm rubber
your glue but bounces off me sticks to
you nana boo boo it's all projection
every [ __ ] bit of it
so yeah it's really [ __ ] dumb
standard error and we have to mock them
for it we have to mock them this is one
of the Republicans Heroes
right here this toxic masculinity I mean
there's a video out there and we can go
watch it too of him talking about how
toxic Max and Lenny is a great thing
it's a great thing okay but let's listen
to his comeback here his playground I'm
rubber your glue argument uh Jesus over
the small dick energy at getalife.com
he and in this video if you catch it he
flashes his nipple I'm going to show you
that but he also admits
he also admits that he has small dick
energy watch
released some greenhouse gases
I'm obviously a stranger to all mine
controversy he's not something I often
do
but now
just the mainstream press is commenting
on the fact that
I was informing Greta there's the nipple
flash did you did you catch it
oh I'm gonna show the camera my nipple
yep why
can you imagine if I just sat here and
just like yeah here's my nipple
it's [ __ ] weird right
that's [ __ ] weird that's gotta be a
[ __ ]
a snowflake mail type thing where you
just flash your nipple oh
that's what he did what do you want from
me I'm I'm just showing you the [ __ ]
the facts here watch here he goes nipple
nipple he touches it he he like hmm he
does like a circular thing with his
finger
look at that
circular yep make a circle on his nipple
and then put it back maybe it itched I
don't know maybe I'm getting out of hand
here maybe he had a nippage
if man flashes nips I'm out he flashes
his nips I'm telling you dude flashed
his nipples
and he he does this all the time he does
like all his podcast and [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he's got his shirt off
and almost all him and he's smoking the
cigar and he's got the stupid [ __ ]
aviators on because he thinks it makes
him look cool I guess I don't know
um
oh [ __ ] oh wait uh man cheetah here uh
[ __ ] chinless wonder he does he
doesn't have a chin
if you go look um like I said if you
Google him go to Google Images there was
a lot of them like old pictures of him
he does not have a chin like if there's
a certain like angle and he doesn't have
the beard to fill out his chin he
doesn't have one
yeah okay so let's let's continue with
what he's gonna say about Greta and
small dick energy see if you can catch
him saying he has small dick energy that
my very extensive car collection with
internal combustion engines which run on
dead dinosaurs have an enormous emission
profile
and she replied by telling me her own
email address
Greta's email addresses
so before he says this
he believes the Matrix and I think he
brings the Matrix up in this [ __ ]
video I think I'm not sure I had to
watch several
Andrew Tate videos unfortunately
yesterday to figure out this stupid [ __ ]
but um
research okay it was research to figure
out who the [ __ ] he is but here's the
thing is um he believes the Matrix is
like a docky series and he actually
believes
that Greta's email was small dick energy
at getalife.com
he believed that
it's hilarious of course I made a joke
yesterday you know about her owning that
URL
but of course she doesn't actually own
it she was owning him not the [ __ ]
email dummy okay let's let's let's
continue with this cringe level of
[ __ ] small dick energy Alpha cut
video
I have small dick energy
why would that be your own email address
listen listen listen real quick make
sure you listen
Greta's email address is I have small
dick energy I have small dick energy you
heard it right here on the Tony Michaels
podcast
Andrew Tate says he has small dick
energy and look he's he's really
confused
he's really confused now I think what he
is
um really fantasizing about is again
this absolute Obsession that these that
these [ __ ] toxic men have with
transgender people right they have this
a [ __ ] obsession with this and the
obsession is I'm telling you this is
what it is they are terrified Andrew
Tate is terrified to go into a bar whip
out his his um his cell phone and show
the the fake pictures of him in front of
all the the the cars that he's rented to
women he's remember he's the tender
swindler
um and he's showing them trying to take
him home now or back to his hotel room
that he's rented that maybe he calls it
his apartment I don't know who the [ __ ]
knows the point is is that he's
terrified to pick up a woman just like
any other person Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro
any of these other these [ __ ] Alpha
Cooks
that that have hate in their heart for
people who just want to be what the [ __ ]
they want to be
and they're obsessed with their
genitalia Andrew Tate is one of them
that is absolutely obsessed with other
people's genitalia
obsessed with it
obsessed
so much so when Greta says you have
small dick energy right
it's just an energy that you have you
you project this thing where you want a
big dick but you don't have one right
and you'll and it's small dick energy is
you you want to have a big huge [ __ ]
like Hunter Biden's [ __ ] so bad
that you project that you there's no way
in hell
that you actually have what you s what
you're trying
claim you have
right it's all fraud so when we it's the
theme of today
but this guy this guy does not quite
understand what Greta is doing here
so much so that he steps in a big pile
of [ __ ] here listen
why would that be your own email address
Greta strange
I mean also I don't want to assume her
gender it's 50 50. but see there it is
again the gender thing he he is
terrified of taking a girl home from the
bar
and she has a dick they're terrified of
it they're absolutely [ __ ] terrified
that they may like it that's the problem
as if that is a problem who gives a [ __ ]
you like it you like it it's not a big
deal Andrew it's not a big deal if you
watch transgender porn it's not that
it's not it really is not that uncommon
with these toxic masculine masculine
males
it's really probably a common issue it's
because they're so [ __ ] upset we
watched the video um I think it was last
week or the week before
where
some [ __ ] you know some [ __ ] toxic
male white male
was talking about how porn turns into
transgender porn and it turns into gay
sex literally that was the progression
of the video
it's what that's why they're so [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] confused
but it's because they're scared they'll
like it which who cares if you like it
or not what the hell's just be you man
be you Andrew be you be you
let's listen
it is what it is
I'm not actually mad at Greta please
bring me pizza and uh make sure that
these boxes are not recycled
thank you so I'm actually mad at Greta
so he has to he has to do everything he
can
everything he can to own the libs here
this is [ __ ] stupid
but again this is why we have to mock
this we have to mock these people
because
frankly you do you think that any video
that comes out of Mar-A-Lago where
Donald Trump's standing in his office
talking about this [ __ ] is any different
than this it's the same [ __ ] and frankly
it's from the same audience the same
audience
this guy's talking to the same people
Trump's talking to
okay let's keep it going here let's see
what's in the
non-recycled pizza boxes Jesus Christ
right because she doesn't realize she's
been programmed she doesn't realize
she's a slave of the Matrix she thinks
I said I knew I brought up the Matrix so
he thinks that Matrix sees a slave and
you're programmed right he thinks we're
all plugged in and I I and and I think
it's the vaccine chip thing that they
got this uh 5G thing going where they
think that because we're vaccinated
we're that's our programming of the
Matrix they are so [ __ ] dumb I I
think he tweeted out before he um or he
sent a message out somewhere maybe it's
I don't know since he got his account
back that he doesn't have sex with
vaccinated women
what he he won't he refuses refuses to
have sex with vaccinated women
as if any woman I mean I guess you're
doing a vaccinated women a favor by
counting them out totally I mean as if
any [ __ ] woman vaccinated or not
would want to be anywhere near this fool
but okay let's continue here with the
Matrix [ __ ] she's doing good someone has
sat her down and convinced her
to try and convince you to beg your
government to tax you into poverty to
stop the Sun from being home
so he thinks Greta's entire idea is to
convince governments to tax citizens
into poverty
so that the sun isn't hot of course he's
trying so hard to do satire here he's
really trying really [ __ ] hard to do
Center he sucks at it and the reason why
he sucks at it is because
alpha male Alpha cuck males suck at
santire I mean have you have you went
and watched I mean Nick Adams
um
self-proclaimed alpha male on Twitter it
the entire [ __ ] account looks like
parody and satire and it's hard to tell
but they are they are parodies of
themselves he clearly does not
understand
why Greta is a climate activist he
clearly does not understand that
he doesn't understand the activism that
she is doing
and what it is for
right clearly does not understand that
but he tries his hardest to make jokes
let's continue Jesus
and then okay I just want to point
something out they can't even he can't
even afford a tripod this guy is
supposed to be convincing us that he is
so wealthy
and he is so great at ideas that he
couldn't even get the idea to have
a [ __ ] tripod
the guy is just someone is holding a
camera
if you're not aware they didn't even set
up a mic for this
so rich so good at this stuff
that he can't get a [ __ ] tripod set
up a goddamn microphone are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me come on
because I called her out on it the
global Matrix got this box Jesus Christ
to like and retweet and all this bought
commenting to try and pretend that her
telling me that she has a small dick in
her own email address
somehow teaches me illness
so it's it's the Bots apparently because
it it there is no way
there is no way in the world and
apparently I'm one of the Bots we did it
live on the show apparently there is no
way that anyone else thought that
Greta's come back was an absolute
[ __ ] dunking on him no possible way
anyone ever thought get the [ __ ] out of
here
welcome to the new episode of the clown
show
but now I know at least
that Greta with a little hate-filled
face
bitter sitting somewhere without eating
on in the cold little hot shivering
use my Tweets we're just gonna make my
Twitter account far more fun
okay
first off dude tastic okay the only
reason why Greta viewed your Tweet is
because you tagged her you dumb
[ __ ]
he's either pretending that he doesn't
know how Twitter works and now Twitter
handles work and notifications work or I
I don't know just like he's pretending
he doesn't have climbs Universe look
it's it's [ __ ] shitbox
and and again I am I'm going to show you
this there's not I why the pizza boxes
what the [ __ ] why in the pizza boxes and
why is there no pizza in them
I don't know and it's like anything else
he's a it's an absolute fraud but why
does this matter you ask you ask me why
does this matter because this is their
entire personality set and when I say
they I mean people who identify as
Republicans
and republican-ish
if there is such a thing nazi-ish
fascist ish
right you [ __ ] break you couldn't
even
Andrew Tate couldn't even considered
Manish
not even close
[ __ ] idiot what a [ __ ] idiot
cringe level [ __ ] couldn't set up a
tripod it took him hours it took him
hours to come up with this
to set up with the stupid robe show them
your nipple man make sure to show them
your nips it's a big issue on the
internet with you
make sure you have a cigar
a big brown dick in your mouth and then
and then let's bring some pizza boxes
because they're not recycled there's
some [ __ ]
you know if you really want it here's
the thing
if Andrew Tate really wanted to own if
if if I was a [ __ ] like him
dipshit-ish right if I was a [ __ ]
like Andrew Tate and I decided to tag
Greta thundberg and talk about my
non-car collection that he did
and then she [ __ ] owns me with a
quote tweet number one I'd probably stop
there but if you really wanted to
if you really wanted to
own granite thundberg in a video
of her quote tweet of you talking about
the 33 cars that you don't own you would
do the video in your garage
in your garage and you would do videos
about every car in the moment not not
the content that you created when you
rented the [ __ ]
but he didn't do that folks and the
reason why is because he doesn't have 33
cars he does not he's never owned 33
cars in his life
he has small dick energy it is the
epitome of small dick energy but why is
so important is because what do you
think all the other videos have you ever
watched the Ted Cruz [ __ ] I mean we
watch some of those clips here
it's the same it's it's the same [ __ ]
it's it's the same [ __ ] when he's
talking about when Ted Cruz is talking
about Mickey Mouse and Pluto [ __ ]
it's the same cringy ass on the libs
type [ __ ]
same bugging [ __ ]
and the reason why is because it's for
the same audience
it's for the exact same audience that's
why it's the same content
now of course this thing has eight
million views this video
but it's not because it's good
it's because it's good oh baby is it
good okay
have we had enough of Andrew Tate for
crying out loud can we not do Andrew
take content for at least at least two
or three days please please Andrew do
not make any more [ __ ] videos
about Greta or your nips or your cars or
pizza boxes please give me at least till
next week
next year we'll do it next year which is
next week good Lord
uh Spigen Ted Cruz Ted Cruz is trending
um and I think it's because he's a [ __ ]
box oh yes he is a [ __ ] box
um and I I believe it's because
um he um
he's talking about
the bidens going on vacation to Saint
Croix and when this [ __ ] packed
up and left and I I brought this up
yesterday packed up and left and went to
Cancun
when the state of Texas got cold
um and because their governor is such a
worthless piece of garbage
couldn't keep the power grid open and so
that's why Ted Cruz is turning Jim
Jordan's trending and these transcripts
dropped um does anyone know
let me go see if um
these transcripts had dropped
what the [ __ ]
now
hmm
oh yeah there's a lot of news about
Southwest Airlines
um I I haven't dove into it a lot of it
has to do I told you
told you we'd have problems with our
travel infrastructure Southwest Airlines
is one of them apparently
um
let's see
is that what's uh okay I don't know Jim
Jordan is George Santos there that's why
he's trending why out that's see that is
how you do it
is you get Jim Jordan trending because
he's George Santos not Al Franken
okay
um let's see what what else Nick Adams
is trending because small dick energy is
trending of course
um Nick Adams is the alpha the
self-proclaimed alpha male
and we went through his thread a couple
times I'm not going to do it again today
just because small dick energy is
trending
we'll leave that one alone
um let's see
why why is it Jim Jordan hey here I'll
show you this inflation reduction Act is
trending at 19.
um and we have Jim Jordan turning at 16.
um Benjamin Netanyahu is turning at
number 26. maybe we'll go in there and
find that let's go in the Benjamin
Netanyahu let's see here um why BB is
trending is there any specific reason
I'm trying to figure out if these
transcripts
have dropped
um let me go do
hmm
I mean Benjamin Netanyahu BB is a
[ __ ] fascist uh but I mean other than
that he's a right winger
what else I had to do
oh
yeah I see
Benjamin Netanyahu is now again the PM
of
um Israel Israel's government has formed
around this corrupt [ __ ]
and Benjamin Netanyahu it looks like
looks like um anyways
so let's move on from that let's go back
to
American politics here inflation
reduction Act is trending I'm really
wanting to see if we can get a link
if these transcripts have dropped
um we were supposed to get the list of
them I'll I'll reshow that here in a
minute once we see why the inflation
reduction Act is trending new
why is this trending
oh yes yes yes yes yes
um it's it's to brag about the inflation
reduction act and how it actually
delivered and for the American people
here's the president of the United
States oh that's not going to want
the reasons I ran for office was to
comfort
the essential threat climate change
poses to our nation to the world
with the signing of inflation reduction
act we took the biggest step towards
that goal in American history
so you have Andrew Tate making videos
about his 33 cars
his 33 cars and Pete's of non-recycled
pizza boxes and
the president United States is actually
signing [ __ ] into law that helps okay uh
let's see
looks like um there is a
Don Jr and Kimberly and transcripts have
dropped here it looks like and let's see
[Music]
um
everyone's saying check my DMs
um who who deemed it to me to my account
or the Pod account
can you text me a link
to this oh here let's just let's just
search this let me uh get out of this
let's go to Don Jr that's the testimony
I'm looking for how many times he played
the fifth uh don Jr let's see if he's
got to be turning here John Jr
transcripts is trending
um here is Hugo But Eric swalwell has it
as well uh no that's from the 22nd yeah
see there's a lot of [ __ ] look at this
let me show you how bad elon's twitter
is
how bad it is so don Jr transcript is
what I searched in Hugo has it here
right and he has new January 6 committee
releases 19 more deposition transcripts
including Christina Bob uh Taylor uh
budwich Stephanie Grisham uh oh thank
you uh I think Margie sent me the link
um Farrah Don Jr that's the one we're
looking for Kimberly Guilfoyle Army
secretary Ryan McCarthy
and uh Steven snood
um but if you look here Twitter Eric
swalwell was posting from December 22nd
hmm
how that works its way up into the
thread nobody knows because it's elon's
Twitter let's see now let's open that
one there come on come on
there we go okay what is this
here's the transcripts okay we got him
um and it's off that actual tweet it is
a thread off this tweet so here's Hugo's
tweet and here are the links
um to the transcripts now I'm not gonna
read them live on air
um because I'm sure they're extensive
you know let's go to the Don Jr one real
quick let me see how many times he says
Fifth Fifth Fifth Fifth Fifth in this
um
you do oh so he did he did State his
name Donald John Trump Jr so he did say
that
um
how many times does he plead the fifth
that's what I want to know that's what I
really want to know
um so I'm sure this will get read
through and we will find it but I'm
gonna retweet uh Hugo's tweet here with
the news and also I'm gonna tweet it
with the links thank you Margie for um
getting me this tweet with the links
um for the transcripts so these are each
one of the January six you can see it's
january6.house.gov and it is the file
for the transcript that coincides with
who the person is
um here on Hugo's tweet so that's a
great way to get to the transcript to
read
to read the trees and the trees and
scripts as they should be referred to
okay let's see if we can find some
excerpts like you know what I almost bet
our friend Allison from before
has something about this probably
and not quite yet she's probably still
reading them when do these drop
when did these drop and it was this
morning it's 9 A.M
and said so it's been several hours
we should have we should have
some facts on these transcripts I didn't
get a chance to read them I apologize I
woke up late this morning what do you
want from me
and I'm gonna be um oh I do have some
news some podcast news we are going to
do the bonehead of the week poll
today
we'll have the bonehead of the week
you'll get to vote for who you want to
be bonehead of the week you vote you
decide me and Gabe Sanchez hopefully
he'll be better by tomorrow we'll break
it down in the second hour of tomorrow's
show
for bonehead of the week so don't forget
to vote you can vote on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod
um as long as Twitter is still up and
running it's had some glitches here
lately
at Tony Michaels pod on Twitter you vote
there you can also vote right here on
YouTube so don't forget to subscribe to
the YouTube channel if you're over on
Facebook head over to YouTube subscribe
to the YouTube channel just search the
Tony Michaels podcast you'll find it or
you can go to thetonymichaels.com all
the links are there
for you to and you got to go to the
community tab so I post the poll on the
community tab for you guys to vote on
YouTube for bone end of the week now
we're gonna do bone end of the week
tomorrow
right in the second hour
but it's gonna be New Year's Eve on
Saturday
and then New Year's Day
on Sunday but we will take off we will
not have a show on Monday we're going to
take one more one more vacation day
I will by Tuesday I should be not
hungover
I won't have alcohol pouring out of me
I'm just kidding I probably won't drink
that much on Saturday usually we stay in
I don't like you know I don't like to be
out and about when everyone's you know
acting crazy
I want to have a nice chill night out so
so we'll probably stay at home maybe
have some dinner or something
but you never know I might drink some
alcohol but Monday
Monday we will be off we will not have a
show on Monday so do not forget and that
we will be back Tuesday Tuesday is when
we'll be back
but we will have bonehead of the week
tomorrow so don't forget to vote today
tonight and when we get it up
as as soon as I can rustle up uh Gabe
Sanchez to figure out who he wants to
put on bonehead of the week I'm sure
Tate will work its way on there and
surely he will
um and and based on these transcripts
there might be some other boneheads that
emerged this afternoon from these
transcripts as the media reads through
them and we we I I'm gonna read some of
these I'm gonna go through the Don Jr
one that's the one I'm interested in of
course the Christina Bob one and [ __ ]
traitor I love that I'm gonna read that
one too maybe I just I'm gonna maybe get
some more coffee in me this afternoon so
um let's see
was there something else damn am I
missing something
am I missing something here
I was gonna talk about something else
[Music]
I know I was
there another video I was gonna show
um see this is why I need my co-host and
executive producer Gabe Sanchez so I
don't forget these things
I thought I was yeah let's see what do
we got
oh no no no no
there we were gonna go uh read the
scripts so let's let's see if we can um
go transcripts
[Music]
sorry about that let's see if we can
find
um
some
um quick excerpts
from question answer from the
transcripts looks like people are still
oh here we go Scott McFarlane you can
always count on Scott oh is that what I
want
here
copy I was on the wrong window
there we go here's Scott's tweet
um he's oh well at first he says that
the transcripts will include Don Jr and
here's Don Jr's the the link to it again
I'll retweet that so you can find that
link pretty easy but here is um here's a
little uh he found something in the
transcript here
and committee transcript shows the panel
asked Don Donald Trump Jr about the 250
million raised by Trump campaign after
the election that is very important
remember they're going to use it for the
legal fund or some [ __ ] to overthrow the
government it's going to be the coup the
cue the coup account
um he's asked if he knows what happened
to the money
here's the question uh does it say who
asked the question it doesn't say
um I was just wanting to follow up with
something that my colleague asked about
the 250 million that was raised I know
you asked I know he asked you regarding
the post-election litigation spending
and the numbers being I think 10 million
or less so here's the here's the idea
and this is where they're gonna the doj
will follow this money the select
committee is pointing it out but doj
will follow the money uh there was 250
million dollars raised for Donald Trump
to try to overthrow our vote in the
court system basically what the court
system steal away our election and our
democracy they raised 250 million
um and the number shows that they spent
10 million or less
of that 250. the questioner says sitting
here today do you know what happened to
the other
240 million dollars
Donald Trump Jr replied I do not
of course I I actually believe him here
would you would you put Don Jr
in charge
of the amount of money it takes to go to
a vending machine and grab a a [ __ ]
bag of chips let alone 250 million bucks
no way would I put him into her I mean
you're gonna you're gonna let him grift
it right you're gonna let him you know
try to rile up the [ __ ] moglodytes to
get them to send money mortgage their
house to send money
to raise a fraudulent fund so you can
pocket it later but you're no one's
gonna put this [ __ ] in charge of
that [ __ ] surely not I mean they're
[ __ ] dumb in the Trump camp they're
buffoons but they're surely not that
[ __ ] dumb that they would let Donald
Trump Jr have anything to do with where
the 250 million dollars was gonna go
so I I honestly
at first glance here I believe that Don
Jr does not know maybe he's like well
I'm not really sure if it was the blow
or the hookers not really sure which one
250 million dollars went to so I do not
know exactly what happened to it not
really sure
so there's a little excerpt from the um
from the transcripts uh here's here's
another one according to the transcript
Donald Trump Jr alleged alleged and
Scott has it here alleged he text Mark
Meadows on January 6 2021 saying the
president
had to condemn this [ __ ] we remember
this text from the January 6 select
committee and they showed this one then
he said has to condemn this [ __ ] and
that Meadows needs to push president
Trump to do so Junior says his dad does
not text
and that he couldn't reach out directly
to president Trump oh man this is and
and here is why
I'm not I'm we're going to read the
script here because we've got a few
minutes left uh in the show but this is
why Donald Trump Jr is so [ __ ] pissed
about Hunter Biden because Joe Biden
texts Hunter probably any he calls and
leaves him voicemails and tells him he
loves him
that's why Junior's pissed off but
here's the script here
[Music]
um
here's the question why did you think
the capital police tweet was not enough
um and this is referring to Donald Trump
sending out a message saying the Capitol
Police you know don't be violent this is
after all the violence this is after
this is after Ashley Babbitt has been
shot because she [ __ ] crossed over
a [ __ ] protected line where the
Capitol Police were protecting members
of Congress and they were using deadly
force to try to get to the members of
Congress so the cops then the police had
to use deadly force against her climbing
through a window
to break through a protected area
anyways the point is is that Donald
Trump sent on a tweet talking about the
capital police
and the questioner again asked why did
you think to Donald Trump Jr the Capitol
Police tweet was not enough
his answer I don't remember
but I didn't think it was enough
question says okay why did you reach out
to Mr Meadows and say
and say not your father directly
well again I think by this time I was
either at the airport or on my way to
the airport
he was out of there [ __ ]
Donald Trump Jr is such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and that guy wouldn't go down to the
Capitol
he wouldn't go down to the Capitol and
and call for Mike Pence to be hanging he
was out of here he was on an airplane
[ __ ] out of here
um here's the question here goes on and
we're gonna have to go we're running out
of time here but there's the last
question
um as you said he's got to condemn it
ASAP
when you said condemn this [ __ ] condemn
condemn what
his answer the violence that that's
going on again you know I think I made
it pretty clear in my speech
we can do this peacefully you know use
your first amendment rights do it that
way
but you know violence has no place in
this situation
um that's oh here here's here's the
answer
um to the question earlier
about the airport he continues on and if
I was on a plane with Wi-Fi my father
doesn't text
so I couldn't reach out to him directly
and reached out to his chief of staff
wait a second
I was on plane with Wi-Fi so he was
using the Wi-Fi to text but my father
doesn't text so he's claiming here that
Donald Trump doesn't text he tweets or
he was tweeting at the time but he
doesn't text everybody go read these
transcripts um this is uh did it do
let's retweet this one uh thank you
Scott for let's let's just put this uh
thanks God for posting these images and
uh reading this through uh and he and
Scott goes on here in this thread so go
go to this thread for Scott McFarland
um and you will see he's picking out
some of the parts of the Donald Trump
Junior testimony to the January 6 select
committee
um for the for the attempt to overthrow
our vote and to commit a Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
and I'm sure we'll have more for you
tomorrow from these transcripts to break
down uh here on the Tony Michaels
podcast don't forget to subscribe to the
YouTube channel right here
hit that subscribe button you're not
going to want to miss tomorrow also
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify
Google make sure to leave us a great
review while you're subscribing to your
favorite directory also follow us on
Facebook if you're on the mind is touch
Facebook page go follow us us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels
and don't forget to vote for bonehead of
the week at the Tony Michaels pod on
Twitter or I right here on YouTube
tomorrow bonehead of the week second
hour I'm gonna get Gabe Sanchez back
here
I don't care what I have to do
tomorrow's second hour bone end of the
week until tomorrow same time same
[ __ ] place Surf's Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon